hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we are in
round eight of our coverage of the 2017
u.s. chess championships White's going
to be played today by Fabiana Caruana
last round did not have the best game
ever but he's going to try to fight back
since he is the reigning champion he
does need to have a good last few rounds
here
his opponents playing the black pieces
21 year old Grandmaster Daniel in that
eight ski playing a really good
tournament so far he has one loss one
win and the rest draws but with the
victory here if you could pull out the
upset would move him up north near the
top of the leaderboard well so we'll go
ahead and get started
Fabiana starts out with pawn to e4 pawn
e6 getting into the fringe defense
pawn to d4 pawn to d5 and then Knight to
c3 and there's kind of three different
variations that black has here he could
take on e4 he could play Knight to f6 or
he could play what he did and that is
bishop down here to b4 we see more
French defense in this tournament and
I've seen in a while there is another
game actually just today that was the
French defense as well for those
following along all the games so after a
bishop to a B for this is kind of
pinning down the knight the knight on c3
is protecting the square here on e4 and
so white really has to make a decision
on how he wants to protect this he
decides to go ahead and play pawn up to
e5 and I like that if you are going to
give up your knight maybe have a double
bishop pair I like having a strong
Center control with your pend to put a
lot of pressure on your opponent's king
side you know if you were to exchange on
the board right here you know maybe you
play Bishop here to try to exchange you
don't have doubled pawns or a lot of
times you just play Knight to f3 but
then after the exchange you just don't
have as good of a pawn structure that's
really attack on the King side of the
board so I really like the approach just
playing pawn to e5 and then after pawn
to c5 then pawn a3 this is the main line
for this specific variation saying hey
bishop you need to make a decision right
now decides to go and get that double
pawn
on the C file as we talked about and
then Queen to a5 so attacking this pawn
why this force to defend that doesn't
really want to play Queen to d2 blocking
in his dark square Bishop this can't
really do anything and then Knight to e2
that just seems even worse because it's
blocking your light square bishop you
really don't want to be fiing killing
your bishop to the King side that often
in this opening so Bishop to d2 somewhat
kind of a forced move Queen to a for
deciding to played pretty aggressive
with this Queen moving a lot instead of
developing as other pieces attacking
controlling this d4 square and then
Queen to g4 and you know right away I
thought we just see nice hood C R to f3
makes a lot of sense simple develop move
protects the square but we do see Queen
to g4 which is definitely the better
option it protects the square and also
attack this pawn here on g7 and black
has two options
I usually opt for pawn to g6 this does
defend it but black decided Dana play
that King to FA giving up his ability to
castle and does not want to go and play
this pawn to g6 so with that
Fabiano for him that's kind of the green
light she wants to start attacking he
knows it's going to be very difficult
you know the knight can come here to h6
we can't come to f6 since he's
controlling it and his King it's going
to have be very difficult for him to
have a lot of protection with his King
since you can't castle it's going to be
hard for him to get these other pieces
over to protect that so that's where he
starts to get his other pieces involved
into the game Knight to f3 pawn to b6
and ask you know he could have tried
something else maybe Queen takes on c2
rook here c1 Queen up efore check maybe
if the Queen comes off the board Knight
up here to g5 night down to f5 you know
Daniel kind of had a decision to make it
almost seems like when he played pawn to
b6 he said I like my position I don't
want to exchange off material even if I
can get this pawn I really like you know
this variation I've studied this he's
moving fairly quickly so at the end of
day Fabiana says cool I'll go ahead and
play pawn to
for now Daniel doesn't have a lot of
great options to take either these ponds
if he takes his pawn here on c4 than
just pawn takes on c5 if you recaptures
Queen to e4 attacking the rook may be
nice to see six it is being protected by
the Queen here of it is pinning that
down okay Queen to c4 would you see an
exchange on board Bishop to c4 97 bishop
up here III attacking this bishop or
this pawn king castle on the Kings side
he's going to have a really strong
endgame with the double bishop pair I
just don't think that's going to be good
for black if instead he decides to take
the D pawn then just Bishop up here to
b4 check maybe Knight to e7 blocking
that pawn takes on d5 it gets really bad
here Queen up here to d7 Knight takes on
d4 maybe the pawns take Bishop takes on
e7 it's not going to really be taking
here because then just clean up here to
g7 that's going to be extremely bad
could see the Queen's him off the board
castle on the Queen side just so much
pressure he still has the double bishop
pair he now has a really good pawn here
on e5 that he can start to push get his
light squared bishop and started
attacking this new square so all in all
this would be extremely bad for for
Daniel so he decides instead of taking
one of these pawns go and play nicely
seven needs to get this activated not
doing too much here on g8 Fabiana
continues Bishop to d3 getting his last
bishop involved into the game so we can
castle on the King side if you want to
now the pawn takes a little bit safer
with the night here on e7 pawn takes on
c5 now the pottery captures Knight up
here to g5 so Fabiano definitely going
for the aggressive route pawn to h6 and
then nice little move of night to h7 the
rook is kind of forced to take there it
looks bad if you have King to g8 we are
to see if the King goes to e8 then Queen
takes on g7 that's bad
if the King comes to g8 then just Bishop
to h6 you can't take this right here
so maybe plays Knight to g6 trying to
break the pin there other than the
bishop can just take maybe pawn captures
and then Knight to f6 check has to
really take it right here
but then you know Queen takes on g6
checkmate if he doesn't take okay well
then it just gets bad from here we see
King to f7 just starts dropping material
Queen to f3 with the discovered attack
coming maybe now the pawn takes on h6
Knight down here to e4 discovered attack
then after nice of these six things get
pretty dangerous for white here he has
the checkmate threats here on f7 there's
just no way to stop all the threats here
Queen to a5 check pawn to c3 it is
protected by the Queen here on f3 rook
to h7 Castle on the Kings side and in
this position it would be very very
difficult you know for black to really
do too much with this outpost here on d6
with Queen just raised to pounce at any
time it would be very tough for black to
hold on to this so he decides to go
ahead and take with his rook here Bishop
takes on h7 a bishop to a b7 just trying
to get the light square bishop involved
into the game castle on the King side
that Knight to c6 rook here to be one
Bishop down 8 to a6 since it was being
attacked a Bishop to e3 Queen up here to
a5 and then a rook to d1 I really like
to setup from white if you're thinking
about what Fabiana is looking to do it's
an open board state he has double bishop
pair which is always good open board so
you can see the control that he has now
that his bishops can kind of control a
lot of the board you can see both of his
rooks they are on these open files
they're controlling a lot of the
critical squares that Daniel may try to
go to and he has a very active queen
with a safe King if you look up black
side of the board you can see he has a
double pawns on the C file his bishop is
on that the rim over here it's not
really protecting too much it's just
kind of blocked by this pond right here
the Queen's kind of acting alone
both the Knights are playing pretty
defensive and it's rook here on a once
not controlling anything it hasn't moved
too much and the King doesn't have too
much safety so although white is looking
extremely good it's going to be very
very difficult for black to one get out
of this without losing and to find any
sort of way that he can have an attack
to potentially win this game he's really
looking for a drawl like besides to go
ahead and gobble up material here on e5
Queen back to g3 attacking the Knights
and the knight or pawn to f6 protecting
the knight that thing rook up here d6
both attacking material here on e6
getting ready to bring his rook over
here to d1 double-barreling put a lot of
pressure on his opponent but also making
sure that it's on a dark square so the
light square bishop for black can't
really attack it so all in all it's
going to be tough for black to really
stop this defense Bishop a curettage c8
really forced to play defensive here
rook to d1 as we talked about 9 to d5
trying to block off this you know
double-barrel rook here but then Bishop
up here to f4 this works not really
under any threat right now so decides to
go and get it's dark square Bishop
involvement of the game a little bit
more rook to b8 yeah you want to control
a file but not really sure that's going
to be doing too much right now Bishop
takes pawn recaptures and then queen up
to e5 says yeah we'll go and just start
gobbling up other material if possible
and now this opens up the door for them
to put even more pressure on the Kings
side since that night is no longer there
Queen down to d2 that says I have to do
something to try to stop this because
you're threatening the rook up to da
check and then all sort of bad stuff
starts happening rook up to d8 even
after the Queen just says I'm not going
to worry about that King to f7 Bishop to
g8 check King down here to g6 Queen
efore and then after Queen to f3 black
decides to go ahead and resign if we
were to continue we might see Queen up
to f4 but then kind of the dagger move
rook to f8 and the King's forced to move
in at the Queen is going to fall going
to be a pretty easy in game poor Fabiana
Caruana so although we did lose the last
game decided to come back play an
extremely good game
with white against the French defense so
congratulations to him
you know Daniel Plata interesting
variation I think he was a little bit
outclassed in this particular game but I
loved the fact that he was trying
something new always tough to play
Fabiana when he does play the white
pieces playing this well but exciting
game only only about 30 or so moved so
wasn't the longest game but definitely
exciting to watch so hopefully you guys
enjoyed round eight and come back
tomorrow and we'll be looking at round
number 9 thanks for watching